I'm very happy we we made it to
Wednesday I feel good about that I
really do nice when you get to Wednesday
it's a nice feeling and I just want to
say happy hump day Andy oh well thank
you Coney you know happy hump day to you
and of course you know where the phrase
hump day comes from don't you oh I do a
lot of people think the phrase hump day
comes from you know it being Wednesday
and Wednesday is a day in the middle of
the workweek but that is not why they
call it hump day
exactly here's the real reason why it's
called hump day in 1846 whale hunting
was a thriving industry along the New
England coast at the time hunters look
for different whales on different days
of the week
blue whales on Mondays sperm whales on
Tuesdays humpback whales on Wednesdays
and so on to the sailors of old
Nantucket Wednesday the day they looked
for humpbacks became known as hump day
and the name stuck and so to this day we
call Wednesday hump day however we don't
call Tuesdays firm
a man Andy okay Wow I hate to tell you
but you are dead wrong
why yeah yeah this is the real reason
Wednesday is called hump day dogs like
to hunt not just on Wednesdays every day
but you can't call every day hump day
that would be confusing so in 1937 the
International Tribunal of dogs voted to
make Friday hump day but that didn't sit
well with the American delegation they
wanted hump day earlier in the week so
they race to Belgium and make their case
before the dogs in court the court ruled
in favor of the American challenge and
moved hump day to Wednesday where it's
been ever since
[Applause]
is hump day right
we have a great show for you
that series baskets community and Louie
Anderson
[Applause]
he quit before he was done just like me